[Music]
[Applause]
all right everybody let's finish up with
one more do good are making a difference
for her neighbors this is what I'm
liking we all know that I believe
strongly in the power of music it can
keep you sane it keep you grounded
therapeutic and that is why I love the
idea behind a New York organization that
has sent hundreds of volunteers
vocalists and pianists to interact with
the elderly in the city over the past
two decades we have the founder of sing
for your seniors on the line right now
watching on NBC New York say hello to
Jackie everybody hi
Jackie
hi so I have to say I did this Stu all
the time with my church whenever I was a
kid and it was such a beautiful thing
like to be able to do so how did this
get started for you how did you do this
well as a musical theater kid growing up
I would always Sing To my great grandma
Dee when I'd visit her in her care home
and I noticed how some of the other
residents would sort of linger in the
hallway and come sort of gather outside
her door and it would create a communal
experience for all of us to connect
through the music so after college when
I moved to New York City I wanted to
recreate that experience so I started
volunteering at a senior center in the
West Village and after a couple of weeks
uh ran out of songs and so I'd invite my
friends to join me and that's where sing
for your seniors was born oh that's
amazing what have you learned from like
the impact of what you're doing well
that musical theater storytelling is
accessible across generations and
cognitive ability so some senior centers
we serve are places where folks gather
to utilize food resources and these
sessions are an opportunity to have fun
and connect and enjoy music together
talk about memories they bring up and
learn more about each other but we also
serve Alzheimer and dementia facilities
where the music we share is a Lifeline
to connection I have experienced people
who no longer have language will all of
a sudden sing all the words to you know
uh Somewhere over the rain with me and
so that's impact of our sessions is very
powerful but it's different for every
community that we serve no absolutely I
was actually going to say that I've
actually um I've worked a little bit
with um the Alzheimer's Community and it
is interesting how they will not have a
conversation with you they don't really
register certain things but when I start
singing especially like standards like
you know somewh the rainbow or any kind
of elephant Dred Frank SN anything like
that it it they sing every word they
know the melody it's like it's a
different part of the brain right and
it's incredible like how alive they
become in that one moment cuz they just
remember that which is such a beautiful
thing I love what you're doing I am more
than liking it I'm loving your post
right now thank you so much for what you
do and that's not all ma'am our season
long partner pilot pin makers of G2 the
go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to honor truly Unstoppable people
just like you ma'am so they're going to
be riding sing for your seniors a check
for $1,000 just to help
out thank you thank you so much and
thank you to all our guests this hour
Nancy Pearl Tim Maggie lyanna and Jeff
remember to check out the Kelly Clarkson
shows Instagram to learn how you can
help select the good neighbor of the
Year have a great day everybody and if
it's not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys
y'all have a great night I'm going
home